reaction continues to pour in over
prince harry and meghan markle's divorce
from the royal family after a one-year
trial run the duke and duchess of sussex
officially declared their independence
friday by announcing they would not
return as working members of the royal
family
roxanna saberi has the latest from
london
[Music]
when prince harry and megan resigned
from their royal duties
and moved to the u.s last march they had
one year to rethink their decision
now it's clear the split is final
after speaking with prince harry queen
elizabeth has confirmed in a statement
that in stepping away from the work of
the royal family
it is not possible to continue with the
responsibilities and duties that come
with a life
of public service the couple will now
give up their royal patronages
and prince harry will lose his honorary
military titles
a move his friends say that will sting
i know that he'll be personally gutted
just as i was that he's not allowed to
pull a military uniform on
anymore but but regardless that doesn't
change his commitment to
the individuals that serve in it indeed
in their own statement the couple
declared
they remain committed to their duty and
service to the uk
regardless of official role adding we
can all live a life of service
it's an unprecedented situation in the
royal family royal correspondent roya
nica
was this decision mutual no it wasn't
mutual
the queen made it very clear a year ago
when they left that there was no
half-in half-out style approach to being
a member of the royal family
you're either in or you're out and
they've decided to be out
megan and harry seem to have embraced
their new lives in california
volunteering striking deals with
streaming giants netflix and spotify
and recently announcing they're
expecting a second child
they're also set to break their silence
on the royal split
in an interview with oprah winfrey on
cbs next month
which nika says the royal family is
bracing for
relations are more strained than ever do
you think they can be repaired
potentially way down the line in the
future but not right now
the palace says while saddened by the
couple's decision to leave
they remain much-loved members of the
family
for cbs this morning saturday roxanna
saberi
london much love throughout the world
and as we mentioned the couple will be
sharing their story with oprah winfrey
you can see it
oprah with megan and harry right here at
cbs it's a prime time special
on sunday march 7 at 8 o'clock eastern
again right here on cbs